alors vous dites les sages du Conseil
constitutionnel dont on attend la la
décision impatiemment vont se prononcer
uniquement endroit c'est-à-dire qu'ils
ne sont pas là pour faire de la
politique mais est-ce que tout de même
le contexte politique ne va pas jouer
dans leur décision je ne le crois pas je
ne crois pas et ça ne serait pas
souhaité mais il y a deux choses il y a
aujourd'hui la décision évidemment sur
la forme de retraite mais aussi la
décision sur le référendum et moi je
crois beaucoup dans ces décisions sur le
référendum je pense que pour sortir de
cette crise politique de cette crise
sociale nous devons aller jusqu'au
référendum ils doivent valider et en
tout cas je vois pas pourquoi il ne
validerait pas la demande de référendum
d'initiative partagée et ensuite il y a
une mobilisation qui sera pour réunir
les 4 millions 800 000 signatures et
aller jusqu'au vote je pense qu'il n'y a
que par le vote que nous pourrons sortir
de cette crise et d'ailleurs les
parlementaires de gauche qui demandent
ce référendum initiative partagé en
déposé une deuxième demande de RIP qui
est serait plus sécurisé au niveau
juridique vous souhaitez vraiment que
cette initiative de référendum
aboutissent oui aujourd'hui on a dit qui
est bloqué et je vois pas comment on
peut aller au bout de ce mandat nous
sommes à 4 ans de la fin du mandat du
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron je ne vois pas aujourd'hui
comment on peut sortir de cette crise si
ce n'est par le vote je crois que je
crois quand il y a une crise de cette
sorte il faut en revenir aux Français
alors ça peut être le vote certains je
le vois appelle à une dissolution peu
importe mais il me semble que le point
de crispation aujourd'hui c'est cette
réforme des retraites donc je pense que
nous devons aller au vote bien
référendum sur cette information et vous
feriez campagne pour ce rythme comme on
l'appelle référendum d'initiative
partagée la première fois pour aider les
citoyens de ma circonscription à
s'enregistrer pour arriver jusqu'au
400000 exactement
et la deuxième fois pour les inciter à
voter contre cette réforme des retraites
donc ce que vous dites si c'est si le
Conseil constitutionnel valide cette
réforme de retraite la mobilisation
contre ce texte doit quand même
continuer
je ne dis pas cela moi je dis que si il
y a aujourd'hui et demain le référendum
il faudra se mobiliser autrement pour
arriver à mobiliser autour des
signatures je pense qu'on en sera là il
y aura plus le sujet de la mission de la
rue le sujet de la mobilisation pour
avoir les signatures parce que 4
millions 800 000 on se rend pas compte
c'est énorme ce RIP a toujours été fait
vous le savez pour qu'on arrive jamais à
son nombre de signature on l'a vu sur
Aéroport de Paris malgré la mobilisation
nous avions à peine atteint un million
300000 signatures je crois mais là c'est
une réforme qui est beaucoup plus
concernante pour l'ensemble des Français
[Musique]